what what the far left does to get away
it's brilliant we talked about the other
day the death by a thousand cuts i think
i actually i don't know if i have it i
do i do actually have this uh this
article
it's called creeping normalcy creeping
normality sorry
and it's the psychological idea of death
by a thousand cuts
a process by which a major change can be
accepted as normal and acceptable if it
happens slowly
through small often unnoticeable
increments of change
the change could otherwise be regarded
as objectionable if it took place in a
single step or short period so the ebay
color
yeah exactly the creeping normality yeah
okay
creepy normality for those who don't
know ebay change its colors
and everyone freaked out and then they
they switch it back right away and then
slowly over a year right over there they
added like one shade of white one shade
and no one noticed that a year later it
was the whole website changed color yep
so this is what the what the far left
has done very effectively
and it's funny when like so there's a
post going around from oh man i got
i got a sidetrack real quick there's a
dude i know that i worked with
and he was a normal journalist
regular guy not overly political
and he was trying to find his path and
he found something interesting
one day when he responded to donald
trump on twitter
oh my he said something kind of not too
crazy
and he got a ton of followers and then
he
started doing it more and more okay and
then all of a sudden you had 10 000
followers
and then i started talking about it and
i was like bro i think you should knock
this off because
these people aren't like real followers
you're not building a brand
you're actually becoming a laughing
stock of the left and the right
like you're gonna have no respect from
people you're gonna lose your job
and he was like i'm gaining a ton of
followers man like people really like
this i was like no they don't dopamine
kicks
yeah there are people on the right who
started posting edgy memes then started
posting really offensive memes
but found that fringe group that kept
cheering for them every time they would
put
something really really edgy yeah and
then eventually they were just off the
deep end
and then banned outright because they
went too far
the same thing happens on the left with
like becoming a reply guy
and this person just goes off the deep
end slowly
replying more and more getting more
followers until finally
they have a horrifying nickname no
respect their career is over
and they're literally just the butt of a
joke yep so i forgot i forgot what the
point i was going to make is before i
got wrapped up i knew you would
yeah because i was like i got to mention
this part because the reply guy thing
really gets to me
you won't be able to smash the like
button do it that's all
it's your smash smash it smash it i love
you
but that's the career choice for some of
these people man yeah
what were we talking about before i went
off on that i don't know biden creeping
reality creeping normality yeah so i was
talking to the reason i brought this guy
up was because
there's a meme by him and people share
it
okay because you know there are plugins
yeah and basically i got a conversation
about whether or not there is a far left
in this country okay of course there is
the democratic socialists of america
have over 70 000 members by latest uh
reported numbers
these are people who hold their meetings
where have you seen the dsa video
which one the one where they're like
point of personal privilege uh hi my
name is tim
he him uh i just want to point out that
the chattering in this room
is really triggering and i am tired of
people like have you seen that video no
oh it's i don't know if i want to though
and then and then and then i got it it's
it's it's
so it's so funny because like the guy
gets up and he goes uh point of personal
privilege um could
please keep the chatter to a minimum
guys please
and then as soon as he says guys you see
someone get up and then go up to the
microphone go
stop using gentle language um
that's actually what happened wait wait
this isn't i'm sorry wait
this wasn't like saturday night live
it's real it wasn't parody it's real
yeah it went viral everybody made fun of
it well but listen listen
not surprising i mean because it's would
something snl would do
to make fun of well we got to talk about
you know the effectiveness
of the insidiousness of what the far
left has been able to accomplish
what is far left in terms of economic
uh the economic scale far left is
command it's cooperative far right
is competitive okay so if you the
further left you go in terms of
cooperative markets it's communism
and the further right you go in terms of
competitive markets it's laissez-faire
capitalism
so if you had someone who said i think
we should have a mixed economy
that's what america is we're a mixed
economy a large portion of our income
goes in taxes but then we have money of
you know of our choosing to spend
and so you have a bit of a command
economy but sort of a free market
yeah we lean slightly to the right in
terms of our market structure
so what would far left be from where
we're standing you could argue that far
left relative to here
is like if we taxed people at 75 percent
or 80 percent
that would be far left that's that's a
lot if you want to talk about literal
the farthest left you can go it'll be
over communism
yeah yeah you don't even get paid you
just do your job and get everyone gets
the same amount of food
same amount of whatever right well i
love i love these conversations i've had
with people about this stuff
i actually got into an uh i got got into
it with the uh the british
socialist party oh goodness and boy did
it not work out well for them
of course yeah but so so does the far
left exist yes there is a large group of
people 70 000 plus
not the biggest organization in the
world that advocate for abolishing
capitalism outright
you can't go further left than that
that's it on the economic scale at least
right on the cultural scale there is no
real far uh i'm sorry i'm sorry there oh
no no no on the economic scale there's
no far right
okay there's like like lukeward casca i
mentioned him earlier there you go
you have a small group of like
libertarian like right-wing libertarian
and caps
but in terms of the major you know large
factions
not a particularly large group of
right-wing full-on laissez-faire
capitalists relative to everything else
so what people call far right in this
country
is typically cultural far-right meaning
traditionalist
and typically economically left a lot of
the people that have been called far
right hold left-wing economic policy
views
so they're basically posting these memes
where they say there's no far left in
this country
and then i say well certainly the dsa is
far left right they they propose
abolishing profit
like there's like they don't they don't
even know what profit means if they're
gonna say that
yeah they're basically trying to get rid
of all monetary transactions
abolish capitalism abolish police
abolish prisons
complete open borders you know total
globalization stuff
you can't get further left in these
people no so yes they literally exist
and there's a different question as to
whether or not the left is more
dangerous than the right but i would say
the the left is more effective in terms
of their long-term strategy
okay which is psychological manipulation
like ill on omar's
speech well emotional yes the
the one we're subtly mentioning that we
need to take down everything
but she did it in a clever way so if
those are not familiar ilhan omar
said that we need to dismantle systems
of oppression
yeah and she said she said so long as
the economic and political system of
this country creates inequality
you know that are you know exist it'll
create inequality and we must conf
we must dismantle these systems of
oppression wherever they exist something
like that yeah basically
so this is this is the clever uh this is
this is a standard clever political
tactic where
if she came out right now and said i
would like to completely
end capitalism and destroy the american
government so
yeah people would be like would you call
that creeping normality yes
exactly just asking the question no no
she wasn't asking the question she said
it but she made sure to say it in a way
where she could have apologists defend
her right that's that's why i brought it
up
she didn't say that destroyed she was
saying oppression
right but she also made a point that it
was like it's not just the the police
systems it's politics and then well she
because she stated that
and then she's she's continued on saying
it's not just that it's
all forms of oppression no matter where
they lie and it's like what do you mean
by that what exactly are you talking
about
well so so so here's here's what i've
what
what uh what worries me a bit there's
there's no
as far as i can tell legit far right
with political power
it's just it's just not a thing they say
oh but donald trump i'm like come on man
he's a moderate he's in the middle and
and and the worst things about him you
can criticize but it's not
policy it's his behavior yeah attitude
and stuff but if
if we're going to go based on not our
personal standards i defer to vox.com
matthew iglesias saying trump was a
moderate and you look at the new york
times scale and it says the republicans
are
our center right not far right yep so
here's what the left does it's very
clever they have allies in media
they seed fake news they create
uh as many lies as possible to smear and
defame you and they all keep saying the
lie over and over and over again it
works
so there are a few people that i'm
friends with that i would consider
progressive or leftist
whenever i try and have a conversation
publicly on like a facebook comment
all of a sudden these far leftists will
immediately
jam up the entire conversation so
everyone leaves
they make sure no one can talk they
start saying nonsensical things name
calling they screech
they get they they make threats and then
all of a sudden everyone's like i'm out
i'm out you want to know what i was told
today
i tweeted this out earlier here let me
read it it's
i i was blown away i mean i've
referenced this conversation this thread
that i've had it all started from me
just saying
happy july 4th to all my fellow
americans
i know we're not perfect but 244 years
ago we laid the groundwork
to to fix anything that needs fixing
basically
yeah you know to live free yeah to live
free and
people just started freaking out and
attacking me
which led to this one particular person
said this to me said let us lead let us
tell you what we need without you having
a dissenting opinion or arguing with us
period
just listen to us without speaking for
once amplify our voices
and do what we are telling you we need
you to do well that's that's
the super liminal to quote the simpsons
right um
i don't know if you guys know the
simpsons reference but it's that episode
where bart is in that boy band
and they're singing even at niagara
which is join the navy backwards right
not a very particularly hidden message
and then when lisa finds out
she she talks to like the band manager
who's actually a recruiter
who's like we have three strategies
subliminal liminal and super liminal
and then she's like super liminal and he
goes yes and then he opens a window and
yells to lenny and carl hey you
join the navy and they're like okay and
then like later you see them getting on
the bus like joining the navy or
something like that
yeah but that like what they're telling
you right there is overt they're telling
you to your face
we like they're telling you we've taken
the ground and we can we we can pull the
mask off and just tell you outright
you are to be subjugated by us that's
what you will do as you're told
it's like no way but so how do they how
do they get other people to support them
and stand behind their calls to action
these are the tactics used by the far
left to suppress
cancel culture for one we will destroy
your job i actually had a guy
threatening to call my employer today
and it was like
i'm not kidding i'm not kidding that's
amazing did you just give him give him
a number i was like i was like do you
know anything about me
dude so listen i got into a a really
great conversation actually
with with uh uh on a facebook post with
somebody i know we've had a lot of great
conversations
this person is rather progressive and
then sometimes we'll take it to like a
private messenger and i'll be like that
was a really great point i appreciate
your time and we're like have a nice day
so i made a comment about the far left
being legit a real threat the things
they've asked for
and somebody responded who was extremely
out of his mind
and so i just ignored it another guy
responded made some really good points
about the existence of the far left and
the far right pointing out the
democratic party right now
and for a long time has never been
ideological okay
and the conservatives the republican
party has actually been ideological for
a long time
meaning that the republican party has
conservatives
they're they rally around and their
their ideologies their view of america
their beliefs
traditional and uh to an extent right
yeah but typically it's basically like
this idea of
america america first trump trumpism
they're unified
the democrats are a loose coalition of
random groups that kind of just
agree to vote certain ways if it
benefits them yeah and i'm like that's
actually a good point if you look at the
hidden tribes report you'll see that
conservatives are 25 of this country
progressives are eight percent
and then most people who vote democrat
are exhausted majority they say
or default or uninitiated okay the
average person voting democrat
isn't really active or paying attention
and so what they argued was
that was me yeah yeah that was me they
argued that it was
now that the democratic party has found
an ideology it's starting to grow and
become more visible
and i'm like it didn't it didn't
completely disagree with the point i was
making
but it made it you know this individual
made a good point a great conversation
okay and i was like wow that's actually
really really smart showed me data and
everything and i'm like
i completely agree yeah there's a really
interesting point about the democratic
party coming from the civil war
and how they've always voted for what
was considered to be more progressive
regardless of what progressive meant
at a certain point progressive met
eugenics in the early 1900s
so the republican party based on this
graph that was sent to me by
a political researcher this guy was a
researcher really fascinating
the republican party has always been
slightly conservative
always but the definition of
conservative changes
they've just stayed true to like in
terms of the
relative society yeah the democrats
fluctuate like crazy
and the republicans kind of stay where
they are okay so even to this day
they are not far right they've never
been far right they've always been
fairly you know moderate yeah and we see
that we see that data presented by pew
research for instance
but anyway this other guy well this
other guy man
oh yeah he's like you will be first
against the wall
wow wait wait you know wait until it
happens blah blah blah
and then out of nowhere he's like and
and he's like i
you know you should be afraid and i'm
going to call your employers
like i said i'm going to call the people
who employ you and i was
like there it is this guy doesn't know
who i am at all
cancel culture i'm coming after you tim
now try that with me listen listen try
to call my employer get me cancer this
is the point
the point i'm thinking about the far
left and their tactics yeah cancel
culture is real
they know it's real and they know they
can go to the average person and say i'm
gonna call your boss and they'll get
scared
yeah and they'll be like no no no please
please please please please and that's
why all the polls
say biden's winning perhaps because
everyone's like yeah i'm voting for
biden
i loved it though i was like i was like
who employs me
yeah what are you talking about i i wish
someone would try that with me you call
me i'd be like here you go here's his
number yep
i wouldn't give out your number you know
you know what i do if someone tried
canceling you or lydia or anybody
what tell us
i take these concerns very seriously i
am shocked
shocked that those words have come out
of adam's mouth and he never told me
i'm going to give him a raise i'm really
impressed with what he was saying
didn't cassandra get a raise for uh from
her paper
oh yeah so for those that don't know uh
cassandra fairbanks
uh it works for gateway pundit but she
also has her own paper and like someone
threatened to cancel her
they hit up the paper yeah they had they
were bombarding her paper
cancel cassandra and then and she
responded from her corporate like
account saying
you know we're shocked and appalled by
this we're absolutely going to take
action immediately by giving her a raise
and a bunch of exclamation points
genius but but here's the point i'm
making right they know
like we mentioned creeping normality
yeah the far left
knows they can threaten you with
violence and you can do
here's what they do they don't say
something like i will hurt you
right what they say is next time i you
know next time i see you
you better you you should be very
worried about the people who and
and you know what they'll do to you they
make sure they don't cross the line to
making an overt threat
an indirect threat but they want you to
feel threatened right and and
actually this person might may have
broken the law because of the
jurisdiction they're in
but then they do things like cancel
culture hey i'm also going to call your
boss
what am i supposed to say to that even
if i had a job let's say i worked at
mcdonald's i'm going to be
am i going to be like oh no i'm so sorry
i agree with you now
right i will delete my posts like what
do they think is going to happen
but it shows that they really do view
this this uh uh
low tier terrorism as an effective tool
it's death by a thousand cuts yeah
cancel culture
it's their new machine gun we're at a
point now where they know
you can't call their boss because they
won't do anything yeah like
the easiest example you got a video of a
dude walking with a six-year-old
daughter in new york city
terrible video shot killed no riots no
protests
no brand message no no no no flags no
facebook nothing
because if it doesn't fit their
institutional control
it doesn't matter yeah that really
pisses me off that video
it tears me apart that tore me up
watching that video
yeah it's messed up so here's what
happens if you
are not in league with their ideology
and you if i were to call this guy's
boss and say he's threatening me they're
gonna be like i don't care
you know i told someone about that i was
making these
these i i was having a private
conversation with with uh
somebody from this thread you know who
is a closer friend of mine
talking about these things that are
happening and
he didn't believe it where where did you
get your information from yeah
i saw the video with my own eyes oh on
youtube
oh you saw it on youtube well youtube
isn't a credible source it's
it's more of a social media platform i
was like
are you kidding me like i saw the video
i watched the girl run away
yeah like how is that how is that not
like something that actually happened
how how explain to me why you're not an
outrage right now
because they want change can happen they
want to hear from some woke journalist
that it happened yeah and they'll
believe it yeah yeah well so here's what
happens
if i call this guy's boss and say he's
threatening me
they're gonna be like i'm sorry about
that but what do we want to do about it
if he calls you know like a theater
workers boss for instance
and says they were you know saying all
these things you know
the theater is going to be like we're so
sorry we'll fire them immediately
because they you know people know what
you're allowed to criticize and what
you're
not allowed to criticize thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you